[Musique]
au début on n'a passé que que du
courrier du du contenu du courrier puis
au fur et à mesure qu'on avançait dans
la guerre on peut en passer des beaucoup
de documents n'a pas cédé on a passé des
microfilms pour qu on a passé des gens
on a passé des gens qui étaient pour le
service renseignement a passé des gens
qui voulaient sauver en suisse
simplement pour se sauver leur peau
on a passé des juifs pour finir vous
avez une idée d'une personne justement
que vous avez fait passer l'autre côté
de la frontière non non parce qu'il
fallait ont marqué rien fallait
absolument marquer fallait pas qu'on
soit ramassée dit qu'on est des nôtres
sur nous parce que nous aurait interrogé
se requestionner dont on marquait pas
je ne sais pas montre sans son 52e
peut-être 200 quand même parce qu'on a
passé pas mal de monde
[Musique]
qu'est ce qu'il y avait dans la tête
c'était quoi c'était un jeu pour vous un
peu oui c'était un jeu était surtout le
plaisir de rouler les allemands parce
que oui parce que moi là en 40 des vu
arriver les allemands j'ai vu défiler
tout est en français j'ai vu arriver les
premiers allemands
au village tout le monde étaient partis
bougent et est restée avec mononc
l'opium no 3 1 donc on a vu arriver les
allemands comme on n'avait pas la radio
à chappes être vu qu'on avait pas
l'électricité
on était un peu surpris surtout nous
usons un peu surpris on les attendait
pas pas si vite que vraiment pas si vite
que ça
heureux on est un peu on était par
exemple on était vexé de voir arriver
des allemands et puis en plus j'ai un
allemand qui m'arrache et j'avais un
petit drapeau français sur mon vélo
il m'a arraché le drapeau en me disant
france fini j'ai fait le point dans ma
poche mais je me suis dit france unis on
va bien voir mais je ne voyais pas ce
qui pourrait ce qu'on pouvait faire
oublier pas la solution
et donc quand friend a proposé dû aider
pour le service enseignant j'ai sauté
sur l'occasion parce que je voulais
faire quelque chose je voulais pas
rester inactifs tous une fois on se fait
tirer dessus
pieds nus tiré à bout portant parce que
c'est très prenant leur tomber dessus
nous devons tous tirer dessus tout prêts
tout près non pas simple passe à travers
j'ai pas mon copain ja pas eu cette
chance la nuit d'après une balle dans le
genou puis de mort
[Musique]